coco ho et ont pu leur cher journal j'ai
une amie qui dit les choses comme elles
les pense contrairement à moi elle n'a
pas peur de vexer les gens qui ont peur
de vexer les gens et c'est peut-être
juste une question gouffre tu vois bon
moi ton manteau je n'aime pas mon
manteau à nos petits jeux enfin
attention c'est pas que j'aime pas si je
le voyais tu vois je le vois en boutique
je me dis waouh
mais jamais j'oserais toi ça te va très
bien mais c'est aussi parce que tu as un
charisme tu vois que j'ai pas peur massé
plus + terme quoi plus
passe partout on voit pas alors que toi
bon direct et non libyens je lui ai
demandé de me coache avant d'aller chez
le coiffeur pour être enfin incapable de
dire ce que je pense vraiment attention
ça plate ça vous plaît et là ça vous
plaît alors elle m'a fait faire tout un
tas d'exercices dont je n'ai pas compris
l'intérêt mais je voulais pas la vexer
donc je préfère décomposer le mouvement
gauche droite gauche droite non gauche
droite du ballon côté gauche
j'ai très vite le rimbaud écoute je
tourne tourne tourne
allez on tourne encore encore laura
enfin c'est pas que j'aime pas tes
exercice c'est juste que j'ai coutume a
demandé de venir pour t'aider beaucoup
de suite tourné stocker tourne tourne
tourne à côté à côté pas autour du pot
pas autour on tourne on tourne à côté
attention ce top écrase voilà bon allez
j'en ai marre tu m'appelles après quoi
faire laura merci pour aujourd'hui
c'était cool là ouais c'était cool je me
suis un juif et chez mais c'était cool
laura oui dis moi je voulais te demander
enfin c'est pas que j'aime pas comment
tu t'exprimes mais j'ai parfois quand tu
dis des trucs comme ça je me disais que
peut-être enfin comment dire c'est pas
très bon cette phrase anna tu veux bien
aller au boulot c'est tu peux fermer ta
gueule
si t'es ok enfin dans le sens où je veux
pas tu imposer quoi que ce soit bon du
coup je suis allé chez le coiffeur et je
n'ai pas osé lui dire que je voulais pas
payer pour le supplément balayage que je
n'avais pas demandé alors c'est pas que
j'aime pas c'est juste que heureusement
que j'ai une tête abonnés quoi
[Musique]